hi guys and this video I want to talk
about the uniqueness of coconut oil it
has some real interesting properties
that I want to discuss number one it is
or fifty percent of it is MCTS medium
chain triglycerides now what are those
those are a type of fat that doesn't
necessarily convert to fat it's used
it's energy and its really good to
induce more fat burning so it will help
you lose weight if the fat that helps
you lose weight and also it's very
friendly to your liver and gallbladder
so it doesn't involve a lot of the bile
and the liver to actually digest this
fat because it merely goes right into
the lymph system through your intestines
and it's used for energy so it's really
good for people with liver problems and
gallbladder issues okay so that's really
cool it has lauric acid there's really
only two or three things that I know I
think palm oil coconut oil and and
breast milk that have lauric acid
lauric acid is a very powerful antiviral
antimicrobial type of fat that helps
decrease viruses it helps your immune
system it's really good for Candida and
funguses so it's a good thing for your
immune system so coconut oil is good for
the immune system good for fat burning
good for energy it also helps you get
into ketosis
that's fat burning because when you're
in ketosis you need something like fat
to allow you go from one meal to the
next that's one of the reasons you
should see some my recent videos and
I'll put some links down below on these
keto bombs keto fat bums so I have a lot
of different recipes now that I'm
putting out there to give people ideas
to camouflage coconut oil like like how
you going to eat coconut you're going to
just like put on a spoon well you can
make little cookies with it and then you
can keep them the freezer the fridge and
consume them at the end of the meal so
it's a way that I consume more fat to
allow you to not be so hungry and go
from one meal to the next so you can
burn more fat so it does help ketosis
vs. going on some low calorie thing or
low fat meal that's really bad and also
actually it promotes good cholesterol
and it actually improves your
cholesterol profiles so coconut oil is
really good for your hair as well good
for the skin it's good for a lot of
things so I just want to point these out
go ahead and start consuming coconut oil
if you haven't already but go ahead and
click the link below and I have some
recipes for you called keto fat balms
check it out thank you for watching